brought to you by total war Warhammer
colossal battles addictive empire
building hundreds of hours of strategic
gameplay order now and get chaos
warriors free hey guys it is Monday my
name is Jeff and you are watching games
buttons an oculus rift update designed
to stop its games being playable on the
HTC vive has backfired subsequently
allowing for full-scale piracy on the
wrist a tool called revive which allows
VR games designed for the oculus rifts
to be played on HTC's by headset has
received an update which bypasses the
rifts drm analyst uses pirate it's
software on may 22 oculus released an
update that conducted platform integrity
checks resulting in rift games no longer
being compatible with the vibe but
revives developer has found a workaround
for this revives creator has said he
does not support piracy and added he
would enable rift games to be played on
vibe and keep ownership checks intact if
it was possible oculus has reiterated
their position on security and say they
will continue to prevent hacked games
from working unsurprisingly a lot of you
guys have bought uncharted 4 over 2.7
million in fact the final installment in
Nathan Drake's adventure racked up 2.7
million sales in its first week that
figure represents sales to customers and
not boxes shipped to retailers as with
me 16 sony revealed that uncharted 4 is
the fastest selling ps4 first party
title to date in North America uncharted
3 drake's Deception reportedly shipped
3.8 million globally on day one although
as it came out later in the ps3's
lifecycle and with a larger audience to
pick it up and finally Final Fantasy 15
director Hajime Tabata has spoken out
about the stranger development of the
RPG Tabata explains there was some
backlash internally
and externally when he took over as the
game's director in 2012 he added that
some of the team was suffering from what
he called Final Fantasy disease
described as people within the company
who can't imagine anything other than
their own view of final fantasy he added
since levert is such a strong
self-affirmation one's own view of Final
Fantasy text more priorities and the
team's success if that view of final
fantasy isn't fulfilled in there
convinced that is bad final fantasy
Tabata added that final fantasy needs to
modernized to survive and he believes
fans have hope for the brand can go even
if they're disappointed in the current
state of the series Final Fantasy 15 is
drew out in September of this year for
ps4 and xbox one let me know down in
that comment section if your keys will
more final fantasy on nut and be sure to
head to gamespot we've got stories on
flat for DLC and mirrors edge catalyst
that's it for me today but to let me
know what mattered to you and I will see
you again tomorrow